here we go one more time how many folks
kind of rile up now so ghost in the
shell' came out this weekend I didn't
see it I said I wasn't going to and the
only thing that would turn me around
would be reviews that indicated that
what I was afraid of in terms of the
story being dumbed down didn't happen
but even the positive reviews that I
read which primarily were in praising of
the visuals pretty much all acknowledged
that it was a simplified story and if
the reviewer was aware of the original
in some cases they weren't but that's
sort of my point here I didn't go by any
one review I went by a spectrum overview
and I'll even single out really the one
that capped it for me was Chris
Tuckman's review it he actually really
liked the film he gave it an a-minus
but he also acknowledged that the story
was simplified now in his case obviously
the visuals being so representative of
the original was enough to raise it up
to a very high place but since my all my
major concerns were on the story that
the story was the weakest part that
confirmed to me that I wasn't going to
enjoy seeing that and everything else
I've read since then bears that out so
why am I talking about this well at home
because of the ending and then the new
twist that they added because you know
what I was prepared to be completely
done talking about the racial recasting
and this movie specifically in regards
to it but it's now literally been made
part of the narratives so if you've got
to talk about the movie at all you can't
not talk about it anymore and in case
you're somebody like me who made the
decision to not see the movie and don't
care if things got suppose waiting for
you I'll sum it up real quick
so at the end the big part of the big
reveal
of how II had been lied to and how her
past had been hidden from her we find
out that the major was originally moto
Co Kusanagi
meaning before she was put in the body
of Scarlett Johansson
she was a Japanese woman so whereas up
to this point the whole discussion of
and I'm gonna use the term that is gonna
friggin trigger half
the viewers but the whitewashing issue
before the movie came out was all meta
it was all about the context of
basically the film's place in Hollywood
and casting within Hollywood and in
within American moviemaking it was an
issue not with the internal workings of
the film but now it is because they've
literally made it part of the plot that
her race gets erased that she was Asian
and she was changed and literally made a
different race Wow
now here's the thing that actually could
have worked to diffuse the overall issue
if it had been more than just a twist
and hadn't been addressed now again this
is where I'm gonna cover the fact that I
haven't seen the movie but I went
through multiple reviews multiple
synopsis I went through multiple
dissections of the ending not to try and
get you know people's you know think
pieces on but to just parse together as
best as I could exactly what was and was
not done in the film and it's what
wasn't done that is the problem which is
that the film acknowledges the race
change but doesn't really deal with it
the idea that her past was a race to the
point of erasing her racial history is
never really addressed and unfortunately
that makes the problem bigger because
had they actually dealt with that had
they actually dealt with what a
fundamental betrayal of who moto
kusanagi was to erase her completely on
a physical racial you know family
history level and just completely
changed the way she looks that honestly
could a I'm not saying that it would
have made the accusations of
whitewashing go away because ultimately
in terms of the the issue of casting
struggles your Hansen still got the work
an Asian actress didn't but it would
have at least led to some a more valid
discussion back and forth and it might
have diffused the thing a little bit in
terms of intentions unfortunately
because they don't use the opportunity
to actually address it it just comes
says tone-deaf like how did nobody in
the course of the writing the shooting
the post-production realized that this
kind of makes it look like they didn't
care and like I get it from a writing
says I get it that they were like well
we can't change the race and then oh
we'll make it an easter egg so it's like
she really is that I can see we're early
in the process where somebody would
think that was a good idea I just I have
a hard time believing that how many
people and processes and layers that a
finished film goes through that nobody
when guys like especially considering
when the controversy around the casting
started happening the film was still
very early in post-production they would
have had time to readjust to do reshoots
to add some extra depth and actually
tackle the issue instead of just having
it there like they're hanging a
lampshade on it cuz but that doesn't
help in a way though it really does
crystalized why this issue is so
divisive because narrative lee speaking
only in terms of film itself while it
does stand as a missed opportunity that
they didn't address you know racial
erasure narrative Lee it is justifiable
that they could take a character was one
race make their her another race within
the context of the story and I think
when I say that's that the heart of the
vibe is because basically and I this is
based off me seeing the flame wars go on
in my own comment section every single
time I talk about this I'm basically
seeing two different sides that aren't
really arguing about the same thing or
they are argue about the same thing but
they're making completely different
points so the people who were more
defensive about the casting of Scarlett
Johansson in this robe pretty much all
we're going on the narrative basis which
is how the film functions in terms of
the fact that it has been part of
versions of ghost in the shell' before
that she may not even firmly remember
who she used to me that maybe she wasn't
even originally moeldoko Kusanagi in the
first place she doesn't actually know
who she was originally anymore I mean
that has been a part of this story at
various points so again there was a
narrative justification
for it but the thing is the people
arguing against it are talking about
narrative they're talking about the
structure of Hollywood they're talking
about societal representation they're
talking about something else now both
these things circle around the issue of
taking a character who is one race
casting them as another race but they're
not actually arguing about the same
thing and I think that's where so much
of the anger comes from because each
side of this debate when looking at it
for the way that they're looking at it
it becomes very clear to them if you're
looking at this setting the narrative
specific asides from a societal
standpoint there are issues of
representation Caucasian people are
over-represented proportionally in
Hollywood produced films this is a
statistical fact whether or not you
think that's a big problem or not that's
another thing but it is true and it's
becoming increasingly true as Hollywood
is branching out and becoming more of a
maker of films for a global audience not
just a u.s. audience but if you set all
the societal implications deciding
you're only looking at the narrative
then the case for that side becomes very
clear the narrative can justify this
decision where's the problem and it just
seems to come down to each side kind of
refusing to acknowledge that they're not
truly arguing about the same thing
they're arguing over the same point but
the angle that they're coming at it from
and the reason for latching on to this
point is completely different and
they're never going to agree because
again they're not actually arguing about
the same thing and I feel like with this
twist and the whole racial thing the
movie tried to split the difference but
it just it would have it would have been
to the movies betterment at least in
terms of renewing the controversy that
already existed now if it had just done
the recasting and then never addressed
it at all in the film because then
honestly it just becomes like any other
adaptation of something from that
originated in another country it becomes
no it doesn't really become all that
different from the departed being an
adaptation of Infernal Affairs or the
ring be
of Ringu and there are still
conversations to be had about those
movies and movies like them but there's
obviously precedent for that that's
something that happens and has happened
and in trying to address it but not
going whole hog and actually making a
statement about what it was they did
just kind of acknowledging yeah we did
that but then not having anything to say
about it kind of makes the whole thing
worse and for me a lot of it just it
keeps coming down to the thing I keep
saying they dumbed down this story and I
think in a lot of ways this exemplifies
that too because they went with just the
Robocop template and instead of actually
addressing the racial change thing which
would have been their way to add a more
thoughtful spin they didn't they just
didn't the opportunity was there to do
something deeper and smarter regardless
of your feelings on the racial politics
of it it was something that could be
addressed and could have added an extra
layer and made this just deeper and in
in a way that would have differentiated
it from the original but still is still
what had something to say it would have
had some bigger ideas and it's and the
opportunity right there they put it in
they just didn't take advantage of it
it's weird but to reiterate the ultimate
reason I skipped out on this film is I
was positive that it was not going to be
on the intellectual level I really
wanted it to be because as great as the
action was in every iteration of ghost
in the shell' was always the ideas that
attracted me more than anything and
those ideas being simplified meant I
didn't want to say the movie and the
general consensus does seem to be it's a
very pretty package but it doesn't have
any lofty ambitions with its story with
its ideas with its philosophical notions
with any of it so let me ask you this
this twist that that the film tried to
do does it in any way for you affect
your opinion of the racial recasting
does it swing you one way the other does
it strengthen an opinion already had
does it make you question the opinion
already had whatever your thoughts are
please drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it I would
politely request that you be respectful
about it we did okay last time we talked
about this the time before that was a
real mess but let's give it a go because
when we can keep it respectful I
actually really enjoy seeing the
discussions go back and forth so
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down
the comments and let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]